there he is patrick sandoval
initially he became a pro out of mission
viejo high school selected by the astros
and this is what he did last time out
this one's hit well to right center
field and it's off the base of the wall
cannon will hit the bag at second with
the juggle he's gonna try for third and
he's gonna be in there
terrific base running by cannon he saw
what was going on in the outfield and he
just kept going
and he ends up at third base just heads
up base running by mark cannon of course
going to the opposite field he knew he
didn't have enough to hit it out
got the high fastball and just muscled
it out to right center right field
and rojas a little trouble having the
ball come off the center field wall
either here legaris but regardless the
bobble right there
and then there's the bubble by laguerra
so he's probably going to be given the
error but heads up base running by canna
goes at the feet first slide grabs the
bag with his left hand to make sure he
doesn't come off
ken is at third with nobody out and
here's matt chapman
2-2 pitch is hit high in the air to
right field
rojas he grabs it he'll throw it in but
it'll be
very late and way off line it's a
sacrifice fly as canada comes in to
score so two batters into the ball game
the a's have a one-nothing lead the is
lead one-nothing the halos bad in the
bottom of the first against bassett
iglesias ohtani in rendon
and a high fast ball and he struck him
out
well i think he said at best kip on the
one pitch a little bit tardy on the
fastball so they stayed with a fastball
and maybe
remembering what happened a couple of
years ago when bassett threw him the
slow curve ball that he hit for a home
run
staying with the hard stuff especially
up and ohtani could not catch up to it
in a swing and a miss
ready at the belt turns kicks here it is
and a fastball swung out of mess at 96.
two k's in the inning for bassett is
ready to go
that one is spoke to right field rojas
misplayed it and it goes past him
ken is going to go to second and stop
there
so that's gonna be a double and it's
also another defensive mistake
by the angels and you have to know when
you play a corner outfielder
at corner outfield what's going to
happen this ball is slicing back
watch this ball start to slice he
basically overruns it he goes and then
the ball is back behind him that ball is
slicing
and you have to play that accordingly as
a right fielder
with a right-handed hitter two on nobody
out
here's loriano
hit hard diving play that's fletcher he
throws to second
and the runner's going to be safe there
so the bases are going to be loaded
so two more hits for l'oreal the bases
are loaded nobody out for matt olson
iglesias the shortstop who grabs it it's
gonna be a double play with
the run coming in to score that's canna
so olson will not get an rbi because of
the double play the a's will get a run
and it's two nothing
so here's shohei ohtani who struck out
in the first
pass it sets and comes to the plate and
a big curve away
and a miss chris bassett pounds the
glove with his fist
as he retires ohtani on the k for the
second
time tonight here's uh jared walsh who
struck out his first time up
high fastball and walsh can't catch up
to it
he strikes out for the second time five
strikeouts for bassett
go between the slow curve ball which he
got ohtani and then this hot fastball
so that's a couple of times walsh has
gotten the high fastball that he
couldn't
hold up on some people analyze the game
wins and losses aren't as important but
to a pitcher
who's one and nine in his career wins
and losses matter he'd like to
get his five maybe further help his team
try to win and get the win
two on one out two nothing is top of the
fifth
bouncing ball to short you bet he can
work through it there's one
that is a double play and a huge
reaction by sandoval that olsen the
first batter left the lefty match up
olson down the right field line into the
corner rojas near the wall and that
baby's gone
[Applause]
matt olson lofts one down the right
field line
leaves the ballpark and it's his 11th
home run of the year and the a's lead
three nothing
85 right down the middle
rojas got turned around on that one two
quick out shohei ohtani
will be in the next batter fastball
broke is bad oh tony's on
he's hurrying for two a hustle doubles
that is impressive
how fast he is another extra base hit
11 doubles two triples 14 home runs
give him now 27 extra base hits
fastball right on the handle of the bat
and he sees how slow that baseball is
going into the outdoor grass he's
thinking double those strides he has
just turns it on boy is he fast
and delivers to rindon swung on a mess
on a fast ball away and bassa works out
of it
ohtani left it second the angels fail to
score
and after six complete the a's lead the
angels three-nothing
nine-hole hitter or ramus garcia
and the first pitch is slammed a deep
left by garcia back goes up into the
track at the wall and into the bullpen
and gone aramis garcia his second home
run as an
athletic and extends the a's lead to
four nothing
jumps on a first pitch fastball in the
seventh from strickland
and crushes it
right over the top and see you later
at the foot down at the bad head through
the zone
sounded great the result even better so
lead off man is on
set brown coming up brown hits one deep
to right field
and that baby's gone
the a's are making the big a look like a
driving range
seven home runs now in this series
now a 6-1 oakland lead two outs here in
the bottom of the eighth
here's shohei batting ohtani
center field tracking loreana it's off
his club
hustling around is iglesia shohei is
flying into third
slides in with three bags
boy is it fun to watch him run shohei
ohtani
two out ninth inning the east lead six
two oh two pitch
swing and a miss he struck him out and
the years of taking the first two games
of the series